Mom! I'm going to a wedding!
Female:
It could have been anyone.
(Travis screaming)
(music)
Grace killed them both
(Grace screaming)
That is hea-vy!
(music)
I was surprised at how quickly
they were able to solve all the
little puzzles last season.
Christopher Miller:
People would freeze frame and
re-watch.
It's time to party!
It's what season two is all
about. It all adds up to
something.
Aha!
I didn't catch on to any of the
puzzles except for when the did
something on the [bleeped out]
It's nothing nasty.
Seeing the forums that sprung up
ten minutes after an episode
came out.
They would have found the
puzzle, solved the puzzle, and
then be arguing about it.
Press "Input".
(Everyone arguing over each
other)
You know what? Shut up!
Christopher Miller:
If you are a casual viewer,
you shouldn’t be able to figure
it out easily.
Help me mommy.
Christopher Miller:
But the clues are there.
Elizabeth Perkins:
There’s clues in words, clues in
paintings...
There's so many clues.
Not a difficult puzzle to solve.
David Kwong:
Chris came to us and said,
I wanna add a bunch of other
layers.
David Kwong:
What can we put on the wall?
What can we have people saying?
David Kwong:
What can we have people wearing?
Dave Shukan:
In After Party one,
It was one puzzle per episode.
-Shock!
There are more puzzles this
season and they are far more
difficult.
And that meant hiding two things
in every episode.
What could we put on each table
that might be puzzles?
I-I gotta walk this off.
Christopher Miller:
It was a gauntlet thrown this
season
Christopher Miller:
to have even more twists
and even more puzzles.
Let’s have some fun!
-Slap
(Music plays)
♪♪
Christopher Miller:
And that’s the trick.
Have a mystery that’s engaging
Christopher Miller:
or people who are just casually
watching,
and the people who are really
intensely watching.
♪♪
Man:
After party in the library!
(Everyone cheers!)
♪♪
All the secrets are coming out.
Time to get squiffy.
(Cork-pops)